mein name ist mal wanne aber kam zu
einer neuen folge die schmeckt was kann
ich denn bringt es verschiedene
cocktails wie wär's denn mit dem change
von cocktails die schöne nicht berührt
für mich gerade wie diese art der video
so die immer so creepy hey was ist an
ihrem zahnarzt und so wie die stadt noch
nicht möglich sein zum beispiel leute es
ist oktober und oktober ist die zeit in
der man zu hause bleibt musikpark
gruselige halloween filme anschaut und
etwas trinken
denn bevor es zur weihnachtszeit über
geldmittel weil aber uns die birne etwas
stärkerem weg richtig starken cocktail
von heute machen wir als allererstes den
james bond cocktail und zu diesem
gamespot da gibt es einiges zu sagen
denn er ist eigentlich total falsch
geschüttelt nicht gerührt ist schon mal
ein großer fehler den man unter den
alkohol spezialisten natürlich nicht
begehen sollte wodka und jin zu mission
soll wohl auch nicht so richtig sein und
viele verwechseln den james bond martini
mit der marke martini also mit der
flasche denn dass es mehr mut ich
verlinke dieses schlechte halbwissen mal
in der infobox damit ich nicht bei euch
würden
ich liebe es keine fakten
hier gibt es nur vermutungen dieser fakt
us tischen sohn früher gab es dort
bewegt deshalb tadel und adi gemacht und
ich mache einfach vermutungen die zehn
vermutung des tages ameisen sind sehr
loyal das wissen nicht dass sie süß sind
ich hab mir auf meinem küchentisch
bilder gemacht stinkt nach lebensmittel
ab 6 j aus dem pott kommen jetzt aber
zum copley rezept und zwar brauchen wir
drei master sword kam ein halbes maß
china ich weiß genau wie es
ausgesprochen wird aber das wird nicht
mehr produziert ich habe ich hier
gefunden ich meine da steht auch wie
leder auf die led- alle franzosen jetzt
so was ist das überhaupt so eine art
wein aperitif oder so dieses ding
besteht einfach nur dass alkohol dem
wundere systems brauchen dringend weil
es auch kein saft abdrehen so und
zitronenscheiben oder bio zitrone denn
nur davon darf man die schale essen
wir brauchen uns dann
wer war eigentlich euer lieblings james
bond meiner war pierce brosnan aber
einfach nur weil ich den namen außen hin
gerne sage euch wegen meinem t-shirt
wundert ist mein abschlussklassen t
shirt aber ich fand es ja aus wie sie
bei so einer barkeeperin und damals 27
sich schon wandelt das ist für uns ein
maß bier ist
[Musik]
es ist das erste mal dass ich auch mit
alkohol arbeite ohne drei kompletten
ballern
also liegt aber nur noch ein einzel ist
zehn vorträgen einer parität zum essen
oder weil man mit sich zum saufen wo ist
das bemühen der verdauung
das ist ein absacker superlative - und
zu helfen
märkische welt für die perfekte größe
alkohol mit alkohol und alkohol
auch wenn keine komplett macht dann ja
dann trinke ich alkohol mit alkohol in
alkohol oder angesetzte mitkommen
jetzt brauchen wir natürlich noch eine
düssel zitronenschale
ich habe irgendwie video mal gesehen
dass sie dann das so dass in zerquetscht
hat dass die aromen sich so verteilen
sowie in james bond mag ein westpaket in
kotka mathematik kommen wir nicht so
ganz hin zu probieren wenn nun der war
diesen drink bestellt und personale
leute um
er hat klasse und nun stellen uns
natürlich wieder der allerwichtigste
frage wann hält man es endlich ihre
schnauze und wie schmeckt von james bond
[Musik]
schon als ob nagellack ist er gut eben
hier soll es auch schmecken
da ist halt einfach nur alkohol drin
wenn ich das probiere dann fühle ich
mich wieder wie dreist sind und nicht
gerade beim ersten punkt denken so
alkohol und zwölf jahre später habe ich
den formaten nämlich komplett macht ja
leute probiert diesen drink auf jeden
fall nicht zu hause aus kann er schmeckt
absolut scheiße und damit hoffe ich euch
hat dieser kleine wie schmeckt's quickie
gefallen und als nächstes kommt ein
anderer cocktail ich verrate jetzt noch
nicht welche es sein wird wenn er
draußen im sparring das hier seht ihr
das gibt auf jeden fall die daumen nach
oben und abonniert main kanals ist nicht
getan habt dass ich okay okay